abone ol
Evet şimdi elinize sihirli bir değnek
Olduğunu hayal edin gözlerinizi
kapattığınız açtınız ve bir mucize oldu
hayatımızdaki en büyük problem Şimdi
burada arkanızda kaldı bu problemi
geçmiş olduğunu nereden anlarsınız Biz
kendi nasıl hissediyorsunuz mutlu
gururlu başarılı Ben sihirbaz değilim
ama yeme davranışı çalışan ve diyetisyen
psikolog olarak birisi bana 62 olursam
süper olacak dediği zaman emin olun En
çok ben karşılık kişinin en hızlı
şekilde süper hissetmesini isterim ama
bahsettiğim gibi bir sihirbaz olmadığım
için süper hissetmedi formüllerinde yok
o yüzden birisi bana altmış kilo olursam
süper olacak dediği zaman bu süper olma
haline anlamaya çalışırım süper olmak bu
kişi için ne ifade ediyor olabilir ama
ben diyetisyen olarak Bu kışın altmış
kilo olma yolculuğunda ona yardımcı
olabilirim ama gerçekten süper hissetmek
için 61 olmak mı gerekir yapmış kilo
olursa ve hala kendi süper hissetmiyorsa
o zaman ne yapacağız
Ama neden kilo vermek istiyoruz benim
kendi yolunda sorduğum ilk soruydu hala
aldığım cevaplar benzer olur sağlıklı
olmak için mutlu olmak için kendime daha
iyi hissetmek için Üstelik Bunu söyleyen
kişiler için bu söyledikleri şeyler de
oldukça anlamlıdır Mesela bir sana
diyebilir ki pırıl Ben Vakti zamanında
60 kiloydum ve kendimi süper
hissediyordum deneyim önemlidir
İnsanoğlu bazı şeyleri değil birçok şeyi
deneyimli öğrenir kendi yada bir
başkasının deneyimiyle ancak ne yazık ki
hiçbirimizin sihirli güçleri olmadığı
için belirli bir ruh haline sağlıklı bir
başarı olarak belirlediğimiz Basic bir
rakam ya da bir gitmeden görüntüsüyle
sağlayamıyoruz Eğer böyle bir şey gerçek
olsaydı ruh sağlığı alanında çalışan
birçok profesyonel bir ömür harcadıkları
terapiler farmakolojik tedaviler yerine
belirli kilolarla belirli istetme
halleriyle insanlara çözüm sunarlar the
mesela Şunun gibi yetmiş kilo olanlar bu
mutsuzsunuz 65 kilo olanlar Siz Bazen
mutlu bazen mutlusunuz altmış kilo
olanlar Siz daha emi mutluluğu
yakaladığınız Ah keşke Ama ne yazık ki
böyle bir şey yok hayatı
değiştirebileceğimiz ve
değiştirmeyeceğim birtakım faktörler var
mesela üniversitedeyken Gece üçe kadar
Parti deyip sabah 8'de Zımba gibi derse
giderdim ben kendimi çok iyi
hissediyorum süper dedim Ha bu arada bir
de 60 kiloydum yılları geri alamam ve
burada F tekrardan belki yapmış kilo
olmam kendimi süre cesetlerle ilgili
bana bir ipucu verebilir ama maalesef
onu bir garantisi yok ya da başkasının
deneyimiyle altmış kilo olan ya da yakın
zamanda 62 olmuş birisinin Dışarıdan
görünen süper gücü olma haline bakıp
sanki Bunun sebebini 61 olmazsa
bağlayabilirim ancak Hiçbirimiz bir
diğerimiz değiliz ve süper hissetmekle
süper hissediyormuş gibi görünmek aynı
şey değil İster kendi deneyimlerimiz
olsun ister bir başkasını deneyim olsun
sistem bu şekilde işlemiyor bu şuna
benziyor Eğer şuradan geçen 3. araba
kırmızı olursa çok zengin olacağım Eğer
altmış kilo olursam Beyaz Atlı prensimi
hayatımın işini bulacağım Herşey süper
olacak ve eskaza Gerçekten bu kışın
altmış kilo oldu O beyaz atlı prensin ve
hayatın işini bozuyor ay nokta olursa bu
kişi gerçekten böyle böyle olduğu için
düşünebilir deneyimsel olarak yani ama
belki daha çok sos yerleşmiştir Belki
daha çok iletişim kurmuştur daha çok iş
başvurusu yapmıştır Bunların hepsi için
altmış kilo olmak gerekir şunu
söyleyebiliriz altmış kilo olduğum için
ben daha çok bunları yaptım ama olmak
zorunda olmakla olduğu zaman olmak aynı
şeyler değildir bir Yine benzer bir
şekilde başkalarının deneyimleri ya da
bizim deneyimlerimizi genelde bu noktaya
çıkartmaz ve İşin kötü olan kısmı şu
noktada başlar ya bu kişi altmış kilo
olduysa ve ne ad ne Prens varsa o zaman
ne yapacağız işte burası bir miktar
tehlikelidir yeme tutumlarını Eğer bir
doğru olarak düşünürsek doğrunun en
başına yiyecekler iyi ya da kötü olarak
etiketleme dediğimiz fiziksel açık topla
göre beslendiğimiz biz bir hak ediş ya o
ceza sisteminin olmadığı noktaya normal
yemek su mu denir Doğru diğer ucunda
tanımlarız buraya Patoloji deriz buraya
da yeme bozukluğu deriz Ancak bu iki
noktanın arasında grilerle dolu geniş
bir alan vardır bu alanda bir yemek Suna
sahip olan kişi resimleri iyi ve kötü
olarak etiketleyebilir hayatını diyette
olduğu dönemler ya da diyette olmadığı
önemli olarak ikiye ayrılabilir fiziksel
olarak diyetin içinde olmasa bile bizsiz
filmiyle ilgili kaygıları olabilir Tıpkı
altmış kilo olmuş ama Beyaz Atlı
prensini bulamamış olan Show kişide
olduğu gibi bu şöyle düşünülebilir bu
sistemde Ben bu yola hedefim süper
hissetmek ve mutlu olmak ve beyaz atlı
prensini işimi bulmaktı ama hala hiçbir
şey yoksa ben bu yolda biraz daha
yürümem gerekiyor işte burası oldukça
Tehlikeli olan bir yer bu durum bu
faktör kişinin gri lerden patolojiye
doğru geçmesi için çok ciddi bir faktör
olarak görünüyor
diş sağlığı konuşalım istersek Tabii ki
beden ağırlığının enzimi ile sağlık
arasında çok kuvvetli bir ilişki var
mesela prediyabet değilsin direnci olan
100 kilo olan bir bireyden ağırlığının
yüzde 7'sini yani yedi kiloyu 6aylık
müdahale kaybettiği zaman spiker diyabet
riski için çok ciddi ciddi bir düşüş
faktörü yakalar
var ama aynı kişinin
1058 kilo olmak istiyorum ve 34 beden
pantolon giymek istiyorum' demesi aynı
sağlık hedefini işaret etmez Bu arada 58
kilo almak tabiri de olabilir Geçen yaz
giremediğiniz pantolon içine girmekte
bir telef olabilir Sadece bu hedeflerin
Diğer sağlık hedefi olmadığından
bahsetmek istiyorum Bunları Bunların
hepsi birer ihtiyaçtır konuşulması ve
paylaşılması gerekir ve ben aslında
bugün Bunun hakkında konuşmak istiyorum
yola daha sağlıklı ya da daha mutlu
olmak için çıktığımız bir başarı olarak
gördüğümüz idealize ettiğimiz bir kiloyu
ya da bir görüntüye ulaşmak için
yaptıklarımızın aslında bize nasıl zarar
verdiğinden en
başarılı olmak Aynen yemek yemek gibi
Tuvalete gitmek gibi bir ihtiyaçtır
nasıl Kimimiz 5 altın beslenmeye Kimimiz
7 8 saat uyur ihtiyaç duyarsak Kimimiz
de başarılı olmaya daha çok ihtiyaç
duyarız Ben fırın olarak başarı ihtiyacı
çok yüksek olan bir ailede başarı
ihtiyacı çok yüksek olan bir çocuk
olarak büyüdüm Annem ve babam eski Milli
basketbolcu
dusenler cantinery öğretmenlikte
yaptılar çok şaşıracak bir şekilde Ablam
da ben de senelerce basketbol oynadık
Hatta anne babamızı yolunu takip ettik
bizde Milli Takım forması giyme bunu ne
kadar eriştik ancak ikimizde
kariyerinize basketbolcu olarak devam
etmedik ama basketbol bize inanılmaz
şeyler öğretti takımı olmayı bencil
olmayı kazanmayı kaybetmeyi Bunlar
başınıza geldiğinde neler yapmanız
gerektiğini altı dakikada duş almayı ve
saçını kurulabilmesi de yine basketbol
sayesinde öğrendim kapıları açmaya devam
etti ablam Amerika'da Ben Türkiye'de
hammadde bu etkinlik burslu okuduk ben
ablama yolundan da bir manevra yaparak
önce Binbir zorlukla elde etmek için
uğraştım sonra son dakika Vazgeçtim
Amerika bunu kenara koyup Türkiye'de
kaldım Çünkü benim bir hayalim var Iğdır
diyetisyen olmak her zaman seneler sonra
Niçin gitsin olduğumu bir parça
düşündüğüm zamanki kararından çok
memnunum herhalde evde konuşulan bir
yakıt depolarını iyi dolduralım
konularından etkilenmiştim şimdi diş
hekimliği ya da atıp okumadığım için
babamın gönlü azıcık kırmış olsam da onu
da gönlünü yaptıktan sonra en sevdiğim
okulun en istediğim bölümünü kazanmıştım
benden mutlusu yoktu
bu psikoloji ile çift anadal başladım
aynı sene Almanya değişim programına
gittim dünya için küçük benim için büyük
değişimler olmuştur
var ama eve gittiğim aynı sene çalışma
grubuna katılmıştım Almanya'ya göç eden
Türklerin yeme davranışını inceleyen
uzun bir çalışmanın Son demeliydi
Türkiye'ye döndüğüm zaman diyetin anlamı
benim için epey değişmişti Her gün aynı
saatte uyumuyordu pergonal saatte
uyuyamıyorum O zaman nasıl Her gün aynı
saatte aynı şeyi yememiz bizden
bekleniyordu anlayamıyordu
bu döndüğüm zaman Yaşım genç Ama her
genç gibi Hayallerim büyüktü ve kendime
yeni bir iddia edilmişti mi insanların
son diyetisyen olmak Ayşe Hanım benim
çok iyi danışanım drone senedir bana
gelir cümlesinin bir başarı olarak
gösterilmesi bana bir miktar tuhaf gelir
geliyordu Ve hala gelir çünkü Eğer Ayşe
Hanım bir sağlık problemi varsa ya da
mesela hamilelik gibi durumu varsa tabii
ki aldı beslenme için üzerine yeni bir
şeyler koyarak ona yardımcı olabiliriz
ama her sene verdiği kiloyu aldı Tekrar
alıp bunun benim kapımı çalıyorsa bu
işte bir terslik vardı kendi yoluna
ilgili anlatmaya devam edeceğim Ama
küçük bir ipucu vermem Gerekirse benim
yolum kesinlikle bu değil de bi ve
geldiğim bu noktaya kadar bana göre
öğrendiğim en büyük şey Teknik olarak en
çok salatanın kazandığı inanılmaz
rekabetçi bir ortamda büyüyen 2 bölüm 1
Master bir yarıda bırakıp 11de
tamamlanmak üzere olan bir doktora sahip
olan birisi olarak elde ettiği başarının
ne bu ünvanlar ne kazandım
şampiyonluklar ne kaldırdığım kupaları
olmadığını anlamış olmamdır başarı
ihtiyacı herkes için farklıdır ve diğer
ihtiyaçlarımız nasıl karşılanıyorsa bu
ihtiyaçlarımızın karşılığında daire
birtakım sinyaller vardır ancak biz bu
sinyalleri ünvanlarla tarzı bir başarı
olarak gördüğünüz rakamlarla da
belirtmeden görüntüleri ulaşmaya
çalışırsak bunun bir sonu yoktur hep
daha iyisi hep daha çoğu vardır başarılı
olduğumuzu nereden anlarız diye
sorarsanız Bazen çok zorlu alsak bile
aldığımız doğumdan anlarız
bu ve dediğim gibi tartıp bu rakamın
bize bu bir başarı elde bir başarı vaat
etmesi oldukça zor olan bir durum olarak
karşımıza çıkar
belirli bir duyguyu ya da Belirli bir
ihtiyacı görmezden gelmekte oldukça
zordur ve aynı zamanda bize zarar
vermeye başlar var Mesela bu durum şuna
benzer
çok aşık olduğumuz ama çok sevdiğiniz
birisiyle işler iyi gitmediği zaman dur
ya artık ben Bunu sevmedim demeye benzer
duyguların ihtiyaçları vardır başarı
ihtiyacınızı görmezden gelmek işe
yaramaz sadece bunu karşılayabilecek
sağlıklı güvenli bir yol bulmak gerekir
Eğer beden ağırlığının denetimine ve
çoğunlukla olarak zayıflamayı başarı
olarak görürsek bir beden kabulü bir
kablolar zincir içine alırsak bu kabul
onay zinciri de zaman içerisinde bizi
içine almaya başlar Eğer bu söylediğim
şeyler Zin için anlamlı geliyorsa ve
içine sıçtınız zincirlerden kurtulmak
istiyorsanız sebebi Ya sen çözüm var
Birincisi sınırlandırmalar yerine
diyetin gerçek tanımına dönmek
sınırlandırmaları yarattığı etkileri
sanıyorum ki hepimiz pandemi de
yaşamışızdır yaşamaya devam ediyoruz dur
ilk kapanmalar geldiği zaman hepimiz çok
büyük bir panik olarak acaba yiyecek
bulamayacak bizim lisesiyle markette
koşup tüketebileceğimiz kadar besini
alıp Hatta aynı heyecanla
sınırlandırılacak düşüncesiyle
tükettiğimiz gibi sonra dedilerki sakin
olun bir problem yok her zaman marketler
açık olacak ve besin orada durabilecek
ve tüketiminizi miktar daha
normalleşmeye başladı
bu daha sonra anca alkol yasağında oldu
o dönem alkol tüketmeyin insanlar bile
Acaba bir daha hiç mi alkol
bulamayacağız enerjisiyle gidip
tüketmeye kadar alkol alıp eve depoladı
ve aynı heyecanla belki etmeye başladı
sınırlandırmalar fiziksel olarak bir
diyetin içinde olmasanız bile besin
tüketimini artıran bir faktör olarak
görülür aynı şeyi belki yine Hedef
olarak koyduğumuz bir kilo varsa mesela
saatlik çeksek Tatile kadar ben hiç
Makarna yiyeceğim dersek Baraj kapakları
açıldığında ve tatile gittiğimizde var
gücümüzle makarna yemek isteriz Çünkü
besinler iyi ya da kötü olarak
etiketlemiş ve aklımda toplumumuza göre
besleniyoruz dur yaptığımız şey ben bu
da yiyebildiğin kadar yim Sanki şu anda
yapılabileceği bir tatmin duygusu varmış
gibi Çünkü döndüğüm zaman zaten çak
anneyi yemeyeceğim deriz bir insanın
besin çok tükettiği zaman sanki kilo
alması ve bir olmuş gibi gösterilir Ama
yeterli ve dengeli beslenmek Pizza
yediniz inersin kabak yemek değildi ve
makarnayı çok yemenin demenin başka bir
yolu varsa biraz daha proteini sebzeyi
arttır demektir bu çok anlaşılabilir de
Çünkü yaşadığımız toplumda bunu
destekler Mesela bir ölüm diyetinde iken
arkadaşlarınız bir kafede Pizza yerken
Sizin bir ısırık kilo almamanız çok iyi
bir irade göstergesi kene ve kadar
tuvaletinizi tuttunuz diye kimse madalya
takmaz duygular önemlidir duygusal
yemeğine çok sık konuşulan bir şeydir
ama fiziksel aktif ve toplu bildiğiniz
zaman gerçekten her çikolata yemeğimizin
bir uygulayan olmadığında
anlayabilirsiniz ikinci vereceğim
tavsiye ve fiziksel olarak aktif olmak
hepsi ödülü söz vardır en iyi egzersiz
yapılan egzersizdir özellikle çok
hazırlandığı bir diyette en son egzersiz
deneyiminiz Tan ter gözyaşı ve Nefret
ede ede yaptığınız bir egzersiz s bir
daha kolumuzu kaldırmak istemezsiniz mi
ama aslında herkesin sevdiği fiziksel
aktivite mutlaka vardır yapılan
hatalardan Bir büyüğü de
kendinize daha sağlıklı ve daha mutlu
olmak için bir hedef koyduğumuz da sanki
o hedefi insanmış da bizim onay aramamız
gerekiyormuş gibi davranma mıdır mesela
her gün 10000 adım atacağız deriz
Çarşamba olur yani üçüncü gün yedin
adında kalırız ve asla yenilmekten
seo-yoon dışında kalmayı tercih edilir
ve hiç adım atmaya başlarız
bu önemli olan şey bizim için fiziksel
olarak aktiviteyi arttırmak ve hem
sağlık için hem de beden ağırlığı
denetimi için damlalarını sürekli ne
artırmak Aslında 3. verebileceğimiz son
tavsiyede beden kabulü ile alakalı beden
kabulü bedeninizin her yerine bayılma
nız değildir aslında
mesela bacağınıza selülitler varsa ve
siz bu seslerden hoşlanmıyorsanız o
sevdikleri bakıp da iğrenç vıcık vıcık
demekle o kaymak gibi demek aynı noktayı
gösterir Çünkü ne gıcıktır ve kaymak
gibidir Bunlar sizin bacaklarınız dır
üstüne selülitler vardır ocakları sizi
ayakta tutar ve siz onları
sevmeyebilirsiniz Bu arada bir denizin
her yerine bayıla bilirsiniz de bu da
bir seçenek ama bayılmak zorunda
değilsiniz bunu kabul ettiğiniz zaman
bedeninizin iyi yanlarıyla da sık sık
karşılaştığımız ı ama daha da önemlisi
sizi siz yapan en büyük değerin
bedeniniz tartı ideal ettiniz bitki
olmadığını anlamaya başlarsınız ne zaman
ki bunlardan bahsetsem abone olmayıp
rekabet mücadelede tutum gelir rekabet
benim yeni filmde var senelerce
kuvvetlendirdi her sene yeni bir
güncelleme geldi ama rekabet ve mücadele
tutun Bazen çok tehlikelidir hırsından
Hatta bu yüzden iki tane tanımı vardır
ya gelmiş geçmiş en iyi basketbolcu
Michael Jordan senelerce antrenörlüğü
yapmış olan efsanevi Android yazacaksın
dediği gibi Michael en kuvvetli yönü
rekabetçi olmasıydı Michael'ın en zayıf
yönü de yine rekabetçi olmasıydı hırsın
Madalyonun iki yüzü gibi düşünürsek
birinci tanısı göklere çıkartır ikinci
tanım kariyerinizi bitirir Benim işim en
çok sayı atmak değil Çünkü sağlık en çok
sayıyı en kısa zamanda attığımız bir
oyun bu beden Aydın denetimi değil
başarı olarak idealize ettiğimiz
taraftaki bir rakam ya da görüntü değil
Eğer böyle hedeflerim olsaydı zaten
diyetisyen ya da psikolog değilim büyük
ihtimalle basketbolcu olur Ha bu arada
basketbolda en büyük bir Yani en değerli
oyuncu olabilmeniz için de en çok sayı
atmanız yeterli olmaz aynı anda giden
fazla şey de yapabiliyor olmanız gerekir
Bir Hayata bir başarı Bir performans
olarak bakmak oldukça anlamsızdır
aslında Çünkü hayat her zaman
istediğimiz gibi gitmez ben bu işe
senelerimi verdim altmış kilo olmayı hak
ettiği gibi bir sistem çalışmaz Çünkü
bir zafer değil Bu bir oyun değil
bu altmış kilo olmanız pislik olarak o
rakımın ihtiyacı ne gerçekten geri dönüp
ona bakmamız gerekir kimse zayıflamasını
asla söylemiyorum sağlıklı konuştuğumuz
gibi gerçekten zayıflamanız gereken
noktalar olabilir ama gerçekten
taraftaki O rakam O görüntüyü okutun
içine girmek sizi ne kadar iyi
hissettirecek ve bütün hisler geçici
mutluluk sadece bir an
küçükken
tennın üflemeye ve bunları bayılırdım ki
hala bayılırım çok eğlendiğim için Annem
artık bir noktadan sonra abartıp
salatanın üzerine Ekmeğin üzerine mum
gitmeye başlamıştı ve her zaman
dilediğim üç tane sabit dileğim vardı
Allah'ım ne olursun Ben annem babam ve
Ablam her zaman sağlıklı mutlu ve
huzurlu olalım ancak sürekli mutluluğun
bir Ütopya olduğunu bu hayatta en çok
sevdiğim insanlardan biri olan annemi
kaybettiğimde Anladım sürekli mutluluk
diye bir şey yoktu ama ben mumları
üflemeye hala devam ediyorum Sadece
tuttuğum dilekler artık sevdiklerimle
daha çok fazla mutlu an geçirmek
şeklinde oluyor hayatı performans olarak
bakmak tartı ki bırak ama performans
olarak bakmak oldukça anlamsız Bence
bunun sebebi saatlerce anlatmamıza gerek
yok çünkü bu bakış açısı bakarsanız Eğer
er ya da geç boyun hepimiz kaybediyoruz
en iyi ihtimalle de en az birkaç tane
acı kayıp deniyoruz Aslında bu şekilde
baktığınız zaman hayat purb edeceğinizi
bile bile bir oyna çıkmaya benziyor O
yüzden bana göre Hayat
kazanılması gereken basketbol maçı değil
basketbolun ta kendisi gibi inanılmaz
keyifli ama kazanmaktan ya da
kaybetmekten değil oyunun kendisinden
keyif almaktan başka daha iyi bir yöntem
bilmiyorum ya o yüzden hayata performans
olarak ya da idare etti müzik
performansları bakmaktansa duygularla ve
ihtiyaçlarla yeniden temas etmemiz
gerekiyor hayatta olduğumuz sürece kendi
Duygularınızı ve kendi ihtiyaçlarınızı
anlayabilir bunları karşılayabilmek için
yöntemler bulabilirsiniz her zaman ve
konu her ne olursa olsun Ama eğer konu
beslenme ve Deniz'le alakalı ise
diyebileceğim tavsiyesi olur bedeninizle
ve besinlerle olan ilişkinizi
düzenlemeliyiz yemeğin bir ihtiyaç
olduğunu Ve muhtemelen de başka bir
ihtiyacı karşılamak için hiçbir zaman
tek başına yeterli olmayacağını
anlamanız ve bütün bunlara bağlı olarak
bedeninizin görüntüsünün değişimini
nasıl Sebebine geri dönmek Onun çıktığı
yere dönmeye niyetli olmak bu işin aslı
bir değnek Biz ve yaptıklarımız iyi
haberse yaşadığımız sürece sınırsız ile
katkımız var teşekkür ederim ya
[Alkış]